con eeuu y francia trabajan en estrechar
sus relaciones lo más reciente la visita
de este martes del secretario de estado
estadounidense anthony blinken en parís
que en comparación con el amistoso
encuentro de hace tres meses éste se vio
más bien como una operación de desminado
un recibimiento protocolario y distante
en el ministerio de asuntos exteriores
marcado por la crisis de los submarinos
el enfriamiento viene desde el último 15
de septiembre cuando australia rompió el
contrato del siglo un pedido de 12
submarinos a francia lo que benefició
una nueva alianza con eeuu y el reino
unido- el anuncio de tono le enojo en
parís que decidió retirar temporalmente
a su embajador en washington en la
reunión anthony blinken buscó restaurar
la confianza con francia podríamos
haberlo hecho deberíamos haberlo hecho
mejor en términos de comunicación esto
es lo que dijeron el presidente biden y
el presidente mckeown cuando hablaron
hace dos semanas el encuentro de los dos
aliados es indispensable para afrontar
los desafíos del futuro como los de la
región del indo pacific ahora una
prioridad para eeuu que busca
contrarrestar la creciente influencia de
china en la región
el pasado mes una llamada entre los dos
presidentes ya mostró la voluntad de
fortalecer sus relaciones y se vienen
más nos pondremos al día durante el g20
y creo que será la ocasión adecuada para
ver cómo podemos volver a comprometernos
de una manera muy concreta se espera que
las diferencias queden finalmente atrás
en octubre cuando joe biden estrecha
manos con emanuel marco en europa